[Music]
there you are
yes being followed by your film crew and
here's my film crew
we have dueling film crews
[Music]
oh were you expecting me yes yeah
welcome
thank you very much come in this is your
office
this is my office the whole house is my
office did you paint them
no these are painted by i painted one or
two i painted that guy see that little
blue and white guy with the
with the bow with the bow yeah i looked
at him oh wow
well you know who paints rhea who's
hiding raya where are you hiding
camera yeah there she is
she paints figures for me
[Laughter]
this messy room is where i actually do
my writing
but what can i see no that's a mess
really like coming to back in the
library i'd love to show you the library
you have to show it to me later it's a
mess
my office as well but i'm not a writer
see i have i have a
this really is my toy soldier this was
like a linen closet here
okay but now
i can't believe it oh my gosh
what are you doing with that i collect
them i i play with them i put them i
arrange them and
in dioramas he has a whole banquet and
so
do you change that sometimes yeah i
change it yeah sure
that's the fun of it getting to move it
around and all that stuff so how long
have you been collecting them how long
uh since 1996 oh wow
is there a shame miniature or tyrion
there are come back and i'll show you
some oh god
but this is my library here you know
forbidden planet robbie the robot
what's his name robbie rafi he's one of
the great robots
i want to have a picture can i touch it
certainly ravi the robot robbie the
robot
[Laughter]
he knows all the dialogue from the movie
he's got the entire dialogue
are you kidding me yeah turn them off
here
but now you see more of my collection
here of uh
of dioramas and stuff like that how many
do you have of them i mean i haven't
counted but you take a look at these
these are cool here these are
these these space men
when i was a little kid in bayonne new
jersey they were selling these things
for 15 cents each yeah yeah like a five
and dime store like wars and kresge's
and so i bought the whole set of these
aliens
see they all have on the base where they
come from mars and venus and stuff like
that
and uh they were not part from a tv show
they were not from a movie they were
just
toys but uh they had to have a story so
i made up a story about them
i decided they were all space pirates i
gave them all names
oh i was probably like i don't know
seven or eight or nine or something like
that you started that early yeah
yeah so do you name the you know each
the name of all
i did yeah they were they were space
pirates that guy with the green guy with
the whole
rocket yeah his name he's john john of
mars he was
because he had a big head he was really
smart and he was the head of the pirates
and
and all that here and a little yellow
guy see the little yellow guy next to
the robot
yeah i couldn't figure out what the hell
kind of weapon he was holding
you know i don't know what it was but it
looked like a drill to me
so i decided he was the torturer
and he drilled into people's heads and
sucked out their brains and found out
their secrets
so i was pretty hideous even as a kid
here
these are the smaller range oh my gosh
that dark sword does um i'm afraid to
breathe
so i have them they come unpainted they
come in pewter
you got to paint them yourself and i'm
not good at painting them so i hire
people to paint them like here's here's
that
here's terry here's tyrion
no wait wait let me see he's got the
whole court there king robert tyrion
jamie there's arya
i can't believe it varys couple
different versions of varys
and where's shea you're shae she doesn't
have any clothes on
oh my god let me see
why did you do that after the um you
know when you
after this series or before actually
before this i signed the contract before
the series
so these are based on the books they're
not allowed to uh
okay because once i sign the series then
hbo gets all the rights
okay so then hbo can do products that
actually looks like you guys
and the dragons here the dragons yeah
i see these are not quite accurate for
my dragons these
these are not my dragons because my
dragons only have two legs
they don't have front legs other dragons
by fantasy riders have four legs and
wings
i just have two legs and wings why why
because it's more
scientifically accurate there's no
animal on earth that has four legs plus
wings
nobody has that sort of thing so even
though it's fantasy i tried
too much of a science fiction guy i want
to make it accurate here
so we'll go off and uh see some of santa
fe now
yes please let's paint how do you see it
let's paint the tone right here's the
town red paint
yes we will rock it george
um may i ask where did you um raise up
where were um mayo new jersey right
outside of new york city
oh okay and when did you come here to
teach santa fe
i came here in 1979 okay
i'd been writing i i sold my first story
in 71
and i sold my first novel in
um but i'd been doing other jobs i mean
i was i was writing i was selling my
work but i wasn't um making enough to
live on
um so i had other jobs i directed chess
tournaments
and i i was a vista volunteer for a few
years
and then i was teaching college i was
teaching journalism in college
in iowa um where i'd wound up
but my books were doing better and
better i was winning awards
each book i was getting more money for
than the last and i
said okay i i'm gonna i'm gonna try to
make the
the leap and see if i can make it as a
full-time writer
and not have to worry about any other
job and so i
resigned the teaching job and once i'd
left a teaching job
you know the great thing about being a
writer is you can live anywhere you want
you don't you don't have to go to an
office every day
you don't have to you don't have to
punch a time clock you just
work at home and you write a book or you
write a short story and then you mail it
off and
they buy it or they don't buy it so i
said well where can i move and oh that's
santa fe that place looked really nice
[Applause]
[Music]
among other things santa fe is a is a
huge arts community
so there are many many galleries here
there are many artists who live here
and it's been that way for for a century
or more
[Music]
this was once uh you know residences
but now it's all been taken over by art
galleries and restaurants and
it's a very fashionable side of town
[Music]
that is valeria the lost kingdom of
valeria from my books
ted painted these for the new edition of
game of thrones that's coming out a very
deluxe
illustrated signed and numbered edition
and sub case
when i first moved to santa fe back in
back in 1979
1980 yes i read in one of the newspapers
it's probably still true but
they said in 1980 there were more places
in santa fe
to buy an original oil painting than
there were places to buy a cheeseburger
running bodies on a gibbet
is it the same painter is it the same
artist yeah ted nesbith yeah this is
these are all ted nae smith he's one of
the great
he's he's one of the big three of
tolkien art he's done a lot of tolkien
paintings
john john howe allen lee and ted nae
smith greatest token artist in the world
and i try to steal them all for for my
own work
but we have many other beautiful things
here wow look at this table
oh my god
wow my style is more you know the dark
ones
it's too much for me here george
did you see that
[Music]
thank you thank you have fun tonight
thank you
you have like turkey town in germany yes
in kreuzberg
in berlin yeah a lot of turkish
community
i like some of that you know the culture
the turkish thing and turkish music
but you know of course the politics
right now i don't like that
right now it's like ah yeah turkish
becoming more
um more like islamic oh yeah it used to
be secular since ataturk
yeah i i know about a little bit at a
turk
yeah right now i mean just stepping can
i say this
two steps back yeah and i have to say
even you know okay i don't like erdogan
so
he's using you know you know he's he's
killing the archers the intellectual
people
they're you know the freedom of this
being intellectual
and um being a teacher even now you know
he's
he's starting now at the schools to to
separate
um girls and boys no
i mean that's not good that's not good
at all
you've been part of the a good movement
on that and doing movies like head-on
and and when we leave that that address
some of these issues that tell the truth
about some of these issues
that's it's cool thank you george i
really appreciate it because it's really
important to me but you know it's not
easy
sometimes it's you know i get i mean
not all of them but most of the turkish
people i guess they that don't like me
it's not real right to do a movie like
when we leave and head on
because it's making us you know it's
making you look bad
yeah making the society look bad so but
it's really really important to me
that's the reason why i'm
working for the organization tear the
farm right
um once i had a speech and the console
is it concerned council just
he left the um room because he was mad
at me because i said
um violence is a part of a
muslim islam um culture
sure and that's the truth i'm sure there
are many positives about the
turkish culture too it is and as well as
the negatives that
absolutely i don't want to be you know
the enemy of turkish culture
because i love the turkish culture i
love turkish people i love turkish music
i love the
you know passion they have it would be
good to have in
if hollywood or or you know some art
film would make
um
a film about uh turkey or istanbul or
something that did did have more of a
complex positive things there haven't
been many movies about turkey there
haven't been many movies about
turks or television shows so
a lot of people have their opinion
based on a movie called midnight express
i know
they think that's turkey
now that was a great movie i know
but it makes you terrified to go to
[Music]
turkey
[Music]
i hear that you uh have uh
you've won a championship at margaritas
yes really and yes
and we are we are known for
wow okay always about the perfect mix
between
the lime juice the tequila
and the orange liqueur so would you like
me to make one
for you first and then certainly i'll
show you that margarita is like
the state drink of new mexico here
really yes with tequila
yeah okay of course tequila in germany
yeah yeah and we use this is
a local tequila santa fe and a wonderful
one we actually tasted it with
a very top silver excuse me tequila
and it went out so then what we use is
fresh lime and lemon and that makes the
difference because you want the
difference between the tequila
the sweet and sour and the orange
liqueur
this is what a margarita is supposed to
be here okay
isabel of course is from germany she's
from sea level i've warned her that one
of these is like three drinks
right uh down where in the homeboard and
i always make sure
you have water my english is not very
well
so if i'm drunk you you you know you
don't
it should be a fun episode
or maybe my english will be better you
know if i'm drunk
come down to my movie theater the
cocktail i'm so happy you bought it and
the answer is no
and i would why did you go on there we
just showed savelle's movie
what is it yeah hold on head on the
movie that started her
uh her career my career yeah is it here
is it still yeah it's at the cocktail
it's playing tonight no no okay now you
can go we will drink and
watch the movie head-on one here
we have to go to maria's and try them
out oh my god
oh yeah before george
so let's drink and then go to a karaoke
bar i want you to sing uh
[Laughter]
and you have to sing for me last
christmas okay
last christmas yeah i don't know that no
all i can do is have donald trump
i've done will travel reads the card of
a man
a night with that armor and a savage
land
oh dancing you see no dancing
[Music]
we will eat a mexican food right so i
should stop now
because i will be but it's so good
how can you stop
[Music]
okay it's getting colder it is where did
sabell go did we lose the belt
i'm here oh there you are
[Music]
now the place we're going for dinner
maria's is a is a family
it it has been a family-owned restaurant
goes back to the 1950s
and they serve traditional new mexican
food i hope you like spicy food because
i like it it is
i mean don't forget yeah i don't know
what turkish food is like we don't have
a lot of turkish food in the united
states
what is turkish food like it's not tuner
you know the other is really typical of
like a burger or are you can i call it
like that
burger in germany here in america is
best known
like to be like a greek gyros no
it's not sorry even i love
greece you know and greek people it's
not i had a fight about that
with david benioff and david said
greek food is much better have you ever
tried turkish food in turkey
no but it's the same i said no it's not
israel it's much better i'm sorry greek
and greece and you know greek
istanbul not consented
[Music]
so welcome to maria's
[Music]
ready for some mexican food yes i'm
ready
this is the margarita man these are all
different types of margaritas
you're joking no they get like 150
different types of margaritas
different types of tequila
right there chips and salsas and we want
to order some appetizers to start here
so let's get some chili cone queso
some green chili egg rolls and uh a
quesadilla
with the bacon and everything yeah okay
so she wants a strawberry margarita
strawberry and i think i'll take the
turquoise tray
oh god it's spicy you should warn me
before
[Music]
do you have some favorite places where
you would like to go
where you haven't been
well
i want to go everywhere you know when i
was a kid
we were poor my family was poor we lived
in the projects
low income projects we didn't own a car
so we never went anywhere i lived in
bayonne i lived on first street
my school was on fifth street so my
world was five blocks long i walked to
school every day i walked back
um i didn't know anything in the world
but i i read i read comic books i read
books
and i dreamed of seeing all these things
so travel has always been
kind of magical to me since i've become
an adult of course and become a writer
i've been lucky enough to travel
do a lot of traveling i've been to
europe numerous times
i've been to germany i've been to
england a dozen times england scotland
ireland
been to france a couple times italy
spain numerous times
but there's still so much in the world
that i haven't that i haven't seen
it is getting harder because you know
i'm getting older i'm not a kid anymore
i'm 66 years old
travel has gotten harder for me it's
it's grueling i get really bad jet lag
sometimes i regret
that i didn't travel when i was younger
you know when i was in college i went to
uh
northwestern university outside of
chicago great school
i had a full scholarship because i was a
very good student so
all my tuition was paid for but you
studied
i'm sorry journalism journalism was my
major
but northwestern was primarily a school
for rich kids every summer
i would have to go back to bayern new
jersey and work a summer job
to earn the money to pay for my books
but all my friends who were
rich they didn't have to work summer
jobs they all went to europe
during the summers and they all came
back with these fantastic stories of
hitchhiking around europe
and having affairs with swedish girls
and i never got to have an affair with a
hot
19 year old swedish girl so i always
felt that life owes me
a swedish girl do you
have your you know your piece here
i well more than other places but i i do
you know
for good or ill i'm famous now i get
recognized everywhere i go you know
it's horrible isn't
yeah yeah that's true but it just never
ends you know
i know you can't turn it off
i mean are people nice to you in germany
you say the turkish community is mad at
you do they come up to you in the street
call your names and stuff um
i got some you know best way since i had
some bad situations like a 15 years old
boy
threatened me or you know said something
bad but it's okay
and you know when they're face to face
they don't have the courage to say you
to you something do you know what i mean
it's like not the internet
right and um it's funny the difference
between
cinema and between tartares and
tartar is like you know it's like they
had me showing this show for 40 years
and it's every summer you can't call
anyone sundays like
my friends to me don't call me sunday at
that time
like okay because i'm watching tartar
okay
but you know it's like that's a popular
show
it is and i asked myself i said okay
it's really hard you know to be that
popular
you know for this series but i like the
show i like to be in the show
i like my part um
now yeah you play a german in the show
yes not a turk no
i didn't i don't i don't speak german
i don't speak turkish
so i only hear you in english yes with a
strong accent but okay and in english
yeah you do have an accent
yeah although it's a hard-to-place
accent i wouldn't call it a terminator i
know
everyone i don't know what kind of
accent it is but it's an accent
do you know what you will never believe
that do you know
what i have here
[Laughter]
it's like i'm obsessed really i'm oh my
god i feel
guilty i'm sorry well it'd be great to
work with you on something again
i would love to you know you got to lose
that accent here
otherwise i gotta run apart for a
[Music]
turkish
[Music]
it was good although i think isabella's
exploding from too much food
[Laughter]
oh yeah i am
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
but you like the food yes the food was
good very much
i really loved it i could eat a bathtub
of that chili corn quesadilla that's my
favorite thing in the world i love this
with the chips and the the you know the
smoothness of the cheese the crunchiness
of the chips the
kick of the spice it's the perfect food
man absolutely
if only it was not fattening
but it is
[Music]
i was raised uh born in new jersey i was
raised catholic but
i i was never really a true believer
and i died neither i stopped going to
church uh when i was in college
we have to adopt these laws because you
know an invisible guy who lives in the
sky said so
i i don't uh i
i don't get it you know
it just seems to me how can any
intelligent person believe that stuff
i know
[Music]
i remember when i was like 12 or 13
years old i had
i guess my first great crisis of faith
it was around the time of vatican ii
and uh you know that pope john the 23rd
it was a great pope
reformed the catholic church liberalized
it in many ways
and they abolished um the the
prohibition
about eating meat on friday oh yeah and
which was in the catholic church that i
was raised in eating meat on friday
was a mortal sin you know they made
differences between mortal sins and
venial sins
and if you died with a mortal sin on
your soul that you hadn't confessed and
been absolved for
you went to hell forever so i remember
after vetement ii i said
let me let me get this straight sister
you know i was in cataclysm
if i may ate meat last friday i would
burn in hell forever but if i ate meat
this friday i'm good no problem
the pope said so i'm okay so
i mean it's just clear to me george i
don't understand you
where are we now here we are great
adventure big adventure comics
hey here we are hello hello
good to see you greetings been a while
hi there hi
and this is sabel better known to you as
shay yeah who betrayed you
oh our pleasure so look see this comics
my comics
actually the week for a new issue of
game of thrones right
that just came out on wednesday really
yeah are you in that are you saying
no i don't think so but because they
don't like shea that much now
after you killed me
[Music]
[Laughter]
do not take your heart to court
she's much more beautiful than i am
[Laughter]
well she's drawn that way this is a
really good comic book have you seen
this one
no this is good saga is probably the
best thing on the rack right now
really yeah to be honest selling wise
and critically it's just
present company accepted yeah well do
you know all of them of course
you know do you know not so much anymore
i know a few
the twilight zone okay i used to work
for them
really yeah one that was my first tv
show back in the 80s
oh okay here's the gaming room
oh there's a real gaming room yeah
they're gaming in their new game
i thought he was joking no
oh wow okay can we go in
no can you you can go in gwen
george
okay
now that she sabella is wandering into
the gaming room there
is she is she going to be safe in there
have they seen a girl before
it could be very dangerous
we have some women gaming in there right
now that's right yeah so what we gave
her
i have never seen like that
[Music]
well thank you guys for hosting us
you're so welcome i mean come by anytime
keep reading comments you guys
[Music]
where are we going now the jean cocktail
oh yeah
popcorn
[Music]
you know i've seen i've seen some other
people i mean i would
cut by san diego comic-con a couple
years ago i was
signing you know that mess signing they
do where everybody sits around that
big circular thing and the fans go past
and everybody signs the same poster
and you just sign it and shove it to the
next person
i was sitting next to lena and there
were some people who wouldn't let lena
sign their poster
no we hate you we don't want your
signature and they would go right past
lina to uh
you know to the next person what yeah
some of these fans are very serious they
can't seem to separate the character
from the actor
george when i was you know at um once
at the comic con i i didn't want to do
it because of that
you know because some people are getting
crazy so i was there
a woman i don't know no she was maybe 45
so you know not a child she was like she
gave me a picture of mine so
please sign it and then she really she
was like this
what have you done i was so scared i was
like
i have to do it i'm so sorry i feel
sorry about that
she was so mad at me just say george
wrote it that way
[Music]
daddy
[Music]
me
[Music]
hey what are you doing here who's
showing the movie head on going how many
more minutes does it have here
oh we have about 30 minutes oh 30
minutes okay
can i have a drink yes you can do you
know chris our head projectionist here
thank you very much thank you
come drink
[Laughter]
we're just humble ordinary people coming
in
okay can you do well the burning
tumblewood
it's a margarita but with oh just really
infused oh yeah i can infuse whiskey
instead of uh the tequila
you can do the substitute perfect with
salt on the rocks
two yeah okay so this is your
theater cinema movie theater it is
and this is our bar where we serve i
love it
alcohol it used to be a broom closet
before i bought it
i heard this theater was a hippie
the building we're in was was built in
around 1910
but it was initially like a fruit
warehouse and a dr pepper bottling plant
it was a brewery for a while
there were offices upstairs there was
once a vietnamese restaurant here
many different things but in 1977
part of this theater this part of the
building
was opened as a movie theater by four
hippies
and it was santa fe's first art house it
was called the collective fantasy
and it was just a basically a big room
with a projector and some chairs
but they showed art house films foreign
films which nobody was showing in santa
fe back in 1977
but in 1984 they sold it to a guy named
richard brandt
and he uh converted it and put up the
marquee and renamed it the jean cocteau
cinema and from 1984 through 2006
the theater was the jean cocteau under
four different owners
but in 2006 the era of the single screen
movie theater was
largely over the multiplexes had taken
over
and at that point the cocktail went dark
so it was dark for seven years
and i only lived 10 10 minutes from here
so i passed by it every day
god i wish someone reopened that theater
just sitting there rotting boarded up
and then one day i drove past and i said
why don't i reopen that theater so i
called up my realtor and i said find out
if we can buy the theater and uh she
found out and the building was for sale
it had been for sale for years nobody
bought it the price had gone down and
down so i
i bought it opened in august so
here we are august uh 2013.
so we've been open about a year and a
half now okay a year and a half
with the reborn jean cocteau i love it
and we we opened with forbidden planet
with robbie robot who you met earlier
yeah okay
oh god to shay
thank you for killing me
it's good spicy yes green chili
wow i'm full of chili today i can't
i'm burning oh
melinda hey
see you kid good to see you
do you know sabel sorry no i'm melinda
snodgrass
one of my dearest friends okay nice to
meet you sometimes collaborator
my right hand on all those wild card
books i gave you
you'll enjoy them they're good she's uh
she's written a lot of cool wild card
characters and melinda is a
television writer and a screenwriter she
worked on star trek the next generation
oh wow okay um you know some cop shows
and things like that and she once had a
pilot of her own
um that she filmed in germany
bobblesburgh
what was it it was in 1996 and
it never went to series but we shot two
hour pilot
on the stage where they shot the blue
angel and um metropolis
oh wow yeah it was in potsdam it was
what was it called
star command okay linda told me the
stories i wasn't part of it but i i
loved the stories no one of mine the
east germans all like
left at five o'clock they left at five i
mean i lived okay it's time to quit
you know that's we're going home wait a
minute we haven't shot that shooting
i literally ran we found out they were
all leaving and we still
had like three scenes to shoot
my offices were up four flights i'm
running down the stairs and i literally
moved myself across the door
and they were like but it's five
three scenes no so then they all sort of
went
oh it was it was an experience five
o'clock
i have to tell you uh where are you
where are you from were you born in
germany or yes
but uh because i went to turkey for the
first time a few years ago
where where did you go i went to
istanbul so you sow more than i
have ever so you have to stay with us
after this
we're going to go to karaoke and she's
going to sing istanbul
okay i can join in and sing it with her
i have to drink more
i suspect george's notions
you are the worst person
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is sabel who starred in the movie
as
sabell yeah that's true was that a
coincidence
was the character name not in the script
um fathers change it i
it was before that it was i think leila
lyla something like that yeah but when
you got the part they changed
they changed to sea belt he fought
because it's my first movie it could be
easier for me to identify
myself yeah okay this is your first
movie
you hadn't wanted to be an actress you
were shopping yes you loved to do
you know absolutely i'm really good at
this and
and they they uh the the casting
director saw you and
said hey you look turkish come yes come
read for us yeah
so but you left out what you were
shopping for
no just wanted to we're you know window
shopping window shopping yeah
because i didn't have the money so
do you have a question about the movie
no i saw it some years ago when
when it first came out oh okay we're
here in santa fe yes have you made other
films
with this director we've had fadi akin
no
no um we are friends and we want to work
together but it was
good you know to separate for after this
strong movie to to go you know everyone
has to go to
their own ways so what's good
it's like like you know having a
relationship and breaking up
growing up and coming back ah
yeah we have questions audience
please don't ask why i betrayed tyrion
i don't want to answer questions yeah
and the bear are bad tidings that we
have to move on to the next program so
the next movie
[Music]
your shay was a lot smarter than book
shay
and book shay had many virtues but she
was not a
a deep thinker
[Laughter]
she was just seeing the stuff that was
immediately in front of them and you
know
the point where tyrion you know
initially when he brings it to the city
in the book how do you have it
how many books have you read have you
read any of books no i started with your
first
game of thrones book in english i told
you i i was still on the first one
yeah yeah okay i didn't want to read it
before you know while i was filming
and now i bought an english one and um i
want to read it in your language not in
german not now
well when tyrion first brings shae to
the city in the books
he gives her her own house like a
mansion
with servants really yeah he sets her up
in this
in this place and he visits her secretly
when he can uh but when he can't of
course she's alone by herself there and
and you know she's bored so she has
singers in and
and and other people uh which he gets
jealous of so there's tension there
between them
so it's quite a different dynamic yeah
but david and dan had to simplify it
i i you know the first season that you
were on night yeah
and knowing where it was going i was
saying
how are they going to do this how is
david i'm going to do this
because you know she really likes tyrion
she really has genuine feelings for him
so how are they going to work the the
the betrayal
at the end uh it's it's not going to be
convincing but
i think they made it convincing yeah and
given the fact that it was genuine
feeling there um it was it was more
powerful
[Music]
[Music]
this is the plaza santa fe plaza the
original end of the santa fe trail of
america's westwood migration
the santa fe trail ended here in the
heart of the old spanish colonial city
are you sometimes you know in summer
like like yeah they have
dancing little concerts and bands and
things like that
texas kept invading new mexico yes
when they were the republic of texas
they invaded us and tried to conquer us
and we
kicked their asses but this was built
after this and of course there were a
lot of indian wars too
so this monument was built to people who
had died in the wars
can you read that here yeah to the
heroes who have
fallen in the various battles with
unions in there in the territory of new
york new mexico okay
but do you notice after with there's
there is yeah that was the
reason why what was there the word
savage
was there oh the heroes have fallen in
the
various battles with savage indians
in the territory of new mexico well
needless to say
the indians didn't like this they tried
for years to get them to remove that
they said this is racist
this is insulting you know why are you
calling us savages
and there was always a big political
debate about it and nobody did anything
you know until one day in the i believe
it was the early 70s
uh an indian in a heart hat and an
orange workman suit arrived here with a
hammer and chisel
in the middle of the day hundreds of
people around and he just climbed over
the fence
and he chiseled out the word savage and
he was wearing an orange suit and a hard
hat so
nobody said anything everywhere well
he's in an orange suit he must be
officially authorized but he wasn't
he was just someone who was really
pissed off at the word savage
so he he removed the word savage nobody
knows who it was
that's a great story it's a mystery to
this day
[Music]
all right we're good
[Music]
dancing
[Applause]
i hope your wife is not getting jealous
of that
i haven't heard of you of us for you
this is from uh from the emmy when we're
in the emmys
yeah yeah thank you so much oh you make
me cry george i
came here this is true
i love you yeah i love you too
they haven't played a a constantinople
assistant
[Laughter]
is saying constantinople yeah
i don't know i don't think he knows it
it's too old
did i know it it's gonna happen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
oh my gosh